the first day all the plans I do
n’t know no one almost didn’t believe I didn’t believe
Then it turned out True, we called our mother
like
Well, in the end we had to put up with it,
of course, very difficult Yes, we drove, we didn’t
sleep at night, we sat sitting We
stopped very little Well, there was a goal to
pick up the children We understood  that we have a
goal As they say there are no obstacles yes We
left everything and all relatives and
loved ones and, as it were, reported where we were,
how when the connection appeared Well, it
was worth it for these joyful faces
to be happy now when we were already
getting on the buses the children who
were staying there  they were crying over the fence
like that, this will
last for a week, then it
was decided for a month and we already went to
another camp Well, yes, she was forced to
get up
[music]
who didn’t get up signed reports
Explain, like, an explanatory letter to the
director of the camp, like Why didn’t you
get up to the Russian anthem  like I didn’t sing it
everything else Well, I wrote something like I
don’t want to get up for this anthem I don’t want to
sing it
myself you can complete it until
five months earlier there was treason but 5 different
misses stay in
the bathroom we don’t accept people closed
like in a separate building then we  began to
say every day that our parents
refused us, that you didn’t call and the documents
were given from us, like that no one
needs us to go there and like We
don’t need all of us